you
there we go all right team black let's
close out of that there we go team black
let's go with the French defense why not
I know the French defense oh okay let's
go d5 for a second I was thinking oh
this is gonna maybe turn into the
pandava Botvinnik structure but not
quite the case because it's not the c
pond that has been capturing on the d5
square so I could pick him up right away
I don't know that I even want to do that
I'd much rather do with the night let's
do that I think I could track him down
without much of a problem let me just
take him right now so I'm looking to
just quickly develop castles from my
rook on I ate it could happen very
quickly alright Bishop check castle rook
here let's do this and I don't have to
take he is defended if Bishop takes
Knight takes I could think about Bishop
f5 and trying to get into the c2 square
so I could try to make use of my Knights
position on the on the white side here
hmm okay so white is making sure that
they could castle this is eight this is
a tame deployment of the bishop but I
think needed a more aggressive post runs
into this so where do we go from here
knight c6 rook e8 bishop somewhere
actually I think I want to move my
knight yeah let's get him out I'm not
sure where my bishop belongs so I'm
gonna retain that flexibility I think
earlier in the stream I was pointing out
that you'll often see the Queen Bishop
development delayed because it's not
completely clear where it belongs this
is maybe a another instance of that
okay not really I don't know that I want
to capture and allow white to no longer
have an isolated deep on so what other
moves can I be considering h6 seems
actually pretty purposeful we do age six
as a flight square Bishop g5 moves later
on can maybe be annoying some pressure
could be placed on my Knight Queen b3
seems like a natural move but it's
actually a losing move Queen b3 I take
the knight and then I take the bishop so
white has to be careful about leaving
with the Queen Queen c2 is maybe a bit
different Bishop takes Bishop takes the
Queen is there to defend laterally but
not so sure about that okay am I not
just winning upon here let me see Knight
takes pawn takes rook takes hmm Knight
takes pawn takes rook takes Knight takes
Knight is now threatening my bishop but
I can take on the d5 square with my rook
and then this Bishop would be in a pin I
think I'm just winning upon actually the
other move to consider his Knight takes
pawn here I'd have to however maybe be
concerned about something like Knight
takes f7 with Bishop check here Queen
check here that can maybe be annoying
but I'm really tempted to just get rid
of the piece that's in my position let
me give you this one more quick view
Knight takes Knight pawn takes Knight
rook takes pawn my queen is unprotected
in that position but she's soon to be
protected after a bishop move
after a couple of captures here if night
takes I take on d5 with the rook it's
the important point I'm gonna go with
that yeah I'm gonna go with that I'm not
seeing it I think I'm just winning upon
here he still needs to get out though my
bishop on seeing I'm not fully developed
so that's something I really start to
question if I'm going for a variation
where I could maybe win upon how's my
development doing in this case it's not
too far backward I don't know if either
side really has a lead in development so
Knight takes I take like this I don't
I'm not necessarily locked into that
okay
well this could be a little bit scary
Knight takes bishop takes my queen is
unprotected Queen takes Queen rook takes
Queen Bishop takes Bishop check our not
Bishop takes Bishop check but Bishop
takes Bishop there's an in-between move
of rook here it's a little bit
uncomfortable I must say if Knight here
there's Bishop takes King takes Queen b3
I feel like I need to do something like
this
c6 are wait what about Bishop e6 I'm
gonna go here my rook is looking a
little stranded I must say I didn't want
to go in for this capture because I had
issues with my back rank I believe I'm
really down on time my opponent has been
throwing up throwing out these moves
very quickly and so let's let's see what
happens here um Knight takes I believe I
take with the bishop first I need to do
that I takes Knight if I'm taking like
this then Bishop takes bishop or maybe
not maybe I could be taken like this but
maybe that would end up in an opposite
color Bishop ending so I I'm up upon if
there's a way to avoid and strictly well
if the my if the only minor piece is
around our case of opposite colored
bishops I'd like to avoid lines that
lead into that type of position f4 is
that gonna be annoying I don't know no
it really can't this I could take the
knight and then I always give this check
and then go somewhere else so I mean I
think I want to take here let me just
put it on the board
yep let's just take care there's no
tricky night move and after the smoke
clears I'm going to I think this is
gonna be a strictly major piece ending
where I'm up upon and I've already made
a flight square for my King so white
will still be needing to do just that
okay and take like this and then after
Bishop takes Bishop rook takes Bishop
okay we're not having that and we're
having something that's actually quite
annoying very annoying actually
42 seconds and now after g4 I'm in
trouble no I could no I didn't have to
do that I could have taken the bishop
because I was on this okay so now I'm
saved
well I was saved earlier but let's just
get right here make sure everything is
nice and cozy and then what c6 just to
reinforce my bishop on d5 and then
Bishop here I like this move just
securing everything making way for a
queen here with Czech actually I like
this square now and then rook here 35
seconds to 30
let's just get there my back rank is
okay but maybe this isn't the most
reliable square anymore
well I could maintain my queen on f6 but
it's not the most reliable square
anymore maybe I could actually get this
pawn rolling just get him up here back
up you know I could have taken that pawn
I take it now I'm on this rook there's a
couple of checks no no I have this back
ring covered I'm gonna I'm on the rook
take that let's check and then
soon-to-be mate well no I'm just winning
that ruck at the end okay
maybe those were just time burners okay
all right Gigi let's go back I was uh I
was nervous right there in that middle
game I saw I was up upon but I was also
at the same time off balance when I won
that pond and I don't know how I don't I
think the better version yeah having
what's the difference between the
pandava structure and this one this is
pretty much arriving well it's a French
defence with c4 inserted I don't have
any problems getting out my bishop one
one thing you experience on the black
side when you're fighting against the
isolated pun out of the pan of structure
out of the pan out Botvinnik attack is
getting the bishop outside doing
something and I don't have that issue I
don't have a pawn on e6 I have both my
Center pawns cleared so development is
not as much an issue when fighting
against this particular isolated pawn
whereas if this pawn is over here you
know I'm having to do it by way of b6
Bishop b7 or one of these things to get
on this diagonal so it's a lot smoother
is what I'm saying and it's it's not as
it's not as difficult to defend I guess
you could say against some some attack
maybe against my own king in fact black
is very quick in getting a rook first on
this completely opened
oops on this a completely opened file
this is not the first time that that
happened let me let me just quickly
bring this up here there we go okay I
should probably go into this all the
time so here let me just flip the board
right now let me look at it from your
perspective so like I was saying it's
gonna be easier development wise for me
to get all my pieces out my queen bishop
in particular get that out and I guess
this just isn't working right
idea of Knight to e5 I don't know how
many problems are opposed for black hair
I think black is maybe already equal
maybe starting to be slightly better
this isn't the most aggressive
deployment of the bishop although again
he kind of had to go here anticipating
this check to bill to block so he is on
e 296 castles rook e8 where is there an
improvement on the white side okay so I
don't think that this is working out so
there must be some improvement here I
wonder if rook e1 is better rook e1 with
an ID of Queen to b3 and then maybe
Bishop d3 or Bishop c4 what what am i
doing when I went on playing on this
efile but well f7 is a bit soft so maybe
it makes sense to a develop the bishop
develop the Queen to an aggressive post
where she is d5 and indirectly f7 but I
think I also have some support with
Bishop e6 since h6 is I did this
initially to kind of stop the Bishop g5
stuff I thought that could be annoying
but even looking at it
deeper I could rely upon a bit better
the e6 square now for my Bishop I have
to worry about Knight g5 stuff maybe
that's an improvement just getting the
rook to e1 with again Queen to b3 h3 as
a flight square also stops my Bishop g4
move yeah that this is maybe my
suggestion here I would suggest Bishop
d3 but this seems very awkward now
you know what these ideas in mind
so that's why I'm suggesting something
like this maybe this first and then
queen bee 3 some some order some order
of moves like this ones to consider but
we didn't have that we went in 495 and
now this drops upon unless I'm missing
something I don't think I am it did seem
a little bit uncomfortable if F for this
is what I was planning on doing taking
here I'm on the Queen however you
recapture I could always do this check
and then move my rook somewhere else or
not even though I didn't have to do that
I could just take because I'm on this so
it seems to just not be working out is
what I'm getting at there's no way to
really exploit the slightly often off
balance position of the black pieces
slightly backward development wise here
on the Queen side Bishop c4 was played I
played Bishop e6 and this was a big
concern I had if I took here on c3
there's Bishop takes and now what two
unprotected pieces if Queen takes Queen
now there's rook takes my rook is hit my
Bishop is hit if Bishop takes Bishop now
there's first this check and then the
recapture and now how do I get out of
this pin and I have to do something
about my f7 pawn so that's why I
couldn't do Knight c3 here or at least I
think so instead I developed my queen is
defended and now the smoke ends up
clearing very quickly this wasn't the
variation but what was played right here
not f4 but rather rather what what was
that next move seeing it in the notation
Knight takes d5 was played we exchanged
a bunch and there's really no I should
have done something different here this
move and then grabbed
yeah just consolidating at this point
I'm up upon and there's really just no
compensation for it and then just crazy
fast moves as the time gets much less ok
I'm not really sure what more to add
with this game but all right good game
in existence